hey what's up guys mkbhd here and today
we're going to be talking about pixel
densities everything you could possibly
want to know about pixel densities in
the last video in case you missed it i
mentioned that the ipad 3 might possibly
have a retina display and a lot of you
guys were thinking that that's a little
bit unnecessary i mean it's just a
tablet why would it need a retina
display things like that so today i hope
to be able to address that let's go
ahead and get started with this video
well the start individual pixels on a
display contain a certain number of sub
pixels for each color and there are
different display technologies like
pentile displays that have less sub
pixels per pixel and therefore tend to
look a little bit worse when displaying
the color that they're missing but for
the sake of simplicity let's assume that
all displays are made up with pixels
with red green and blue sub pixels now
when we're talking about resolution we
tend to refer to it in its simplest form
the x by y form where x is the number of
pixels in the horizontal direction and y
is the number of pixels in the vertical
direction a full hd display for example
would measure
1920 pixels across by 1080 pixels down
or 1920 by 1080. so when i want to talk
about pixel density we need to measure
the number of pixels on the display and
divide it by the size of the display the
area so here in america we use pixels
per inch as silly as inches are so we
multiply the horizontal resolution by
the vertical resolution to get the total
number of pixels on the display then
multiply the horizontal size by the
vertical size of the display to get the
total area in square inches divide the
two numbers and that's how we calculate
pixel density so retina display a term
dubbed by apple is really any display
with a pixel density so high that the
retina of the human eye cannot detect
individual pixels from a typical viewing
distance the iphone has a resolution of
960x540
on a three and a half inch screen giving
it a pixel density of 326
pixels per inch and you're typically
using an iphone less than two feet away
from your eyeball so again the higher
pixel density the better when it's that
close to your face now just about any
phone display with a pixel density of
around 250 ppi or higher will look
excellent from such a close range but
not every phone has such a high pixel
density as you can see here there are
quite a few that come nowhere near that
now moving on to tablets now when you're
using a tablet you're using it from a
little bit further away so pixels can be
a bit bigger before your retina can
detect them people use a tablet from
roughly three feet away from their eyes
so the average pixel density for tablets
drops off a bit the ipad 2 comes in at
132 ppi and the motorola zoom and asus
transformer prime at 150. you can
occasionally see pixels at this density
but usually not but this is why people
are looking forward to a high resolution
ipad 3. and then we move on to computer
displays which have stuck around the
same resolution for years the typical 24
inch monitor has a resolution of
1920x1080
which gives it a pixel density of just
91 ppi and it doesn't stop there take a
lower end 19 inch monitor with a
resolution of 1280x1024
86 ppi and while you may be inclined to
believe that your precious apple
thunderbolt display is superior in
clarity seems very sharp it's really not
this 27 inch monitor comes in at 2560 by
1440 giving it a pixel density of 109
putting it right in line with other
displays in that size and that price
range of course we use desktop monitors
from a little bit further away maybe
four feet from our eyes so we typically
don't notice so much lower pixel density
then of course there are tvs now we sit
much further away from tvs so pixel
density drops off again here a 42 inch
1080p tv has a pixel density of just 52
ppi i'm sure when you were young you
looked up at the tv up close and noticed
the red green and blue dots that made up
the picture yeah you were looking at
subpixels there so there have been
rumors about a retina display macbook
pro but i wouldn't put any money on it
the real bet here is in high resolution
tablets next in fact the asus
transformer prime tf 700t tablet has
already been announced and will be
available later this year with a
1920x1200 display and samsung has
rumored 11 inch tablet in the works with
a resolution of 2560 by 1600 the same
resolution we see on a lot of 30 inch
monitors today the ipad 3 like i
mentioned in my last video is rumored to
have a resolution of 2048 by 1536 on
that 10.1 inch display bringing it to a
pixel density of 528
ppi overkill
probably but will it be beautiful
absolutely so this has been an mkbhd
video thank you for watching if you
enjoyed it please give it a thumbs up as
that really does help out a lot and i'll
talk to you guys in the next video
thanks for watching
peace
[Music]
you